one of my best friends uh we went to uh
the Royals baseball Fantasy Camp M and
they tell you Hey guys you're not as
young as you think you are you know you
know don't everybody's GNA try to get
out there and get some just go easy all
right go easy and we're like yeah no
that makes sense that's good advice I
appreciate that first time I got a hit I
sprinted out of the batter box for first
base I pulled both I pulled both my
quads oh yeah both my quads I think my
hammy I don't know and then of course
I'm out the field and people were like
like you okay I'm like I'm good I'm good
I'm so good heard three pops but I'm
someone hits it to me so I I instantly
go from a stand still to a Sprint I blow
out the other no I was so every I pulled
everything within a matter of days my
arm I I threw out my arm I had to like
attend the night I'm like I got Tommy
John surgery this was all in a matter of
two or three days fantasy C from a
fantasy baseball
camp the Honeydew with Ryan
sickler